what a crocodile like what the [ __ ] and
I believed you and I was listening to
you and I was receiving everything you
said figure
liar Khloe Kardashian was literally all
of us while watching the series premiere
of who lose the Kardashians after news
of Tristan Thompson's paternity Scandal
went public I think a lot of what is in
the media is sort of things that we feel
we need to film because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that Chloe and Tristan
split back in December 2021 after she
found out the NBA star was having a baby
with another woman I can't hear about
this for months about what an idiot I am
like what a dumb I am all these things
from everybody else so when the famous
family's new series debuted a few months
later in April and showed footage of
Coco and Tristan before their breakup it
was cringy and awkward you know how I
feel about you and
you know you know I want to you know get
us back together and build our family
and hopefully be able to expand our
family one day God willing Flash for
word to season
get to see how Chloe reacted to watching
that scene with a room full of people at
the series premiere when I was watching
the show and Tristan was on and telling
oh and where I don't even know what he
said because I like blacked it out but
it was like oh we're just so great or
whatever the [ __ ] he's like hopefully be
able to expand our family one day God
willing
yeah she straight up yelled liar just
own whatever it is is anyone else
getting flashbacks to 2019 you know when
Chloe yelled at Tristan on the phone
after he was caught in a cheating
scandal with Kylie Jenner's former
bestie Jordan Woods
[Music]
[Applause]
of course I'm sorry Unapologetic as much
as I can be anyway I felt as if the
whole theater was staring at me like and
I was just like this is so awkward
because it's like what a crocod like
what the [ __ ] and I believed you and I
was listening to you and I was receiving
everything you said for your
liar
and it just came out I probably made it
a lot more Awkward than it needed to be
Story of My Life
back in August Chloe and Tristan
welcomed their second child together a
son via surrogate the two also share a
four-year-old daughter true my favorite
part about being a mom I mean it's so
corny but it's just like no matter how
tired you are whatever you just it's
complete Bliss and a source recently
told E.T Chloe is doing well and trying
to gauge the dynamic of her relationship
with Tristan but that will come in time
you know definitely when you go through
things in life those things can steal so
much of your happy moments but tonight
really reminds me that I have to make
myself do things because then I would be
missing out on something so special like
tonight was so fun I don't want my
personal dramas or traumas to take away
all the fun that I could be having
foreign
[Music]